a comedy show is comedy for musicians
but everyone is welcome this is you do
some jokes in this that are very
specifically for because you are a very
talented musician that's very
specifically for musicians jokes that
musicians will get yes maybe to the
exclusion of other people or no you
think other people you know other
people's I've been doing it as a sort of
tour and my hope is that other people
who are not are do has everyone a
musician in the audience here and kind
of so everyone everyone yeah well I
don't say everyone that's a weird thing
you know you're all magicians here right
you never know and so I do these jokes
that are specifically for musicians and
my hope is that other people will go
along with them anyway I mean for
example I'm gonna give an example I'm
not expecting you guys to laugh in fact
sometimes even when I do this in my
standup but people are puzzled by it
no so I talk about musicians wait you
found you found a great formula yeah I
you know they're different musicians or
guitar players bass players I find that
horn players like trumpet players and
stuff they never talk about music they
only talk about money really it's the
strangest thing
they're always like uh you know I got
paid for this one thing twice because it
was a wedding and it was on a boat and
and they I never hear a trumpet player
go like I wrote the most beautiful song
on the trumpet today I don't think
anybody writes on the trumpet do they
and nobody sits there and goes like wah
wah wah it's an inch right on but what
should they know what about Chuck
Mangione yeah I can't believe that two
people are in my face saying what about
Chuck Mangione
that hasn't happened in 230 years man
what about Chuck Mangione side
prior to your anti Brassica just saying
I'm sure it's a fine instrument but you
know it's a kazoo with an attitude just
making in all seriousness we do love
horns right oh yeah I said that to cover
my ass and then you got all sincere and
I'm like not that much you do great
you know I cited this once you do great
an impression of people listening to
different kinds of music and and you do
I was gonna ask if you would do I really
like it when you do an impression of a
guy hearing doo-wop yeah so is this
someone hearing due up for the first
time yeah it's just that like heavy
metal now like rock music is so heavy it
gets heavier and more dense as time goes
on so by that logic if you go back in
time to the 50s there was a time where
doo-wop music was like the heaviest
thing you could ever hear it was the
Matt it was it was like in slow people
mind it was insane yeah so I like to do
my impression of a guy going to the to a
doo-wop show in the 50s and he is so
into it cuz it's the heaviest thing he's
ever heard so I have to stand for it
okay maybe I'll stand maybe I'll stand
right here how's this what a bold choice
[Applause]
this is I'll put the band up there the
band is playing up there this is a guy
watching a doo-wop show hit it anytime
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that guy didn't sleep for three weeks
now that experience you talked about it
for weeks incredible Wow I gotta get
more this do off in me is a fantastic
who are those guys yeah where'd you
think about it--that such a you what you
you have these great left brain ideas
I've been in comedy for a long time and
I'm always intrigued when people have an
idea I'm like how the person think of
that were you listening to do when
you thought of that it's it's oh it
seems to happen if I'm in a car and like
you know the driver or whatever will put
it on that's always the way I'm like
what we know yeah yeah yeah it happened
sometimes with classical music I'm like
who is this for
do people really and I don't mean no
disrespect but I'm like do people really
get into classical music yes they do
yeah they do people take it very
seriously and I I respect that I think I
still think no horns are but
classical music yeah yeah seriously yeah
really I don't know why I'm taking a
fight with the horn player to the world
I have no skin in that game but yeah
people do really get the you know people
people care a lot there's so many lulls
like the classical just coming anything
yeah and it just disappears in this it's
the spaces between the No
I always like to end on sort of an
awkward silence